I'm just a clone alright let's get our
ass back to this yeah whenever you load
up the game it always kind of just spits
you out at a random location either it
likes using campus of ESU or for no
reason at all over way back over at Aunt
May's house
I need this collectible give it to me I
need it I have a problem and I need it
give it to me they're off why is it
stuck there again
why is everything got to be so hard
alright let's just Webb's if our way
over there
alright so I've already compiled a cool
kind of little list of questions from
part one that I wanted to answer someone
asks if I miss the ultimate universe and
I think the answer overall is no because
parts of it were cool and then parts of
it had like major problems like for
example you know the that time meta well
I mean like Quicksilver and Scarlet
Witch is incestuous relationships in
that time the Captain America was like
hey guys that's kind of not okay and
they're like ah cap you're just
old-fashioned that's totally normal in
society nowadays or yeah I thought it
was a little stupid when everyone ever
just decided that their favorite thing
in the world was cannibalism around the
time of ultimatum or like suddenly Reed
Richards becomes a bad guy like to see
the ultimate universe started out neat
but had a lot of problems going forward
I mean I'm in Queens I like listen you
heard me yes you I don't know what
happened I don't know how many days
passed but I don't even know how I'm
still alive if you can call this alive
that was actually one of the scenes that
got adapted directly into the comic a
few years later because uh Brian Michael
Bendis wrote both this game and the I
guess I tagged that point he wrote both
this game and the ultimate comic and
give or take a little bit the intro of
the game is essentially just like one of
the random comic arc from like issue a
38 through 40 or something it might be
more than that they absolutely had to
have put this in here because everyone
hated that side mission from spider-man
to like there's no way they even use the
same sound file hey how you doing kid
for the hell are your parents let them
running away and cower in fear well
regardless I'll be seeing ya thanks for
the thanks for the life force or
whatever uh what was I talking about
oh yeah Brian Michael Bendis wrote like
ten percent of the story of venom in the
Ultimate Universe in the comics then
wrote this game as a sort of way to fill
out the rest of it because through the
development process they were like what
if we had you uh you know get to have
the ability to play for the spider-man
villain and the focus-test kind of
generally yielded that everyone loves
venom because venom is venom and why
don't you love venom you know so he
wrote the rest of the story here and
then just decided to work it into the
comics about four years later in 2009
kind of wish that loading screen didn't
spoil what was about to happen but you
know whatever nice man
Oh
hey wait a minute that's not ultimate
Wolverine he doesn't have that shitty
looking soul patch that hurt me - but it
hurt you so it was worth it so when this
game came out I was absolutely like
head-over-heels in love with it as soon
as they announced that venom was going
to be the other playable character
because before like any of the other
characters I got into like Deadpool or
daredevil or Punisher or Batman like my
two main were were Wolverine or not
whatever venom and spider-man like I
thought I had suddenly action figure as
an poster like maybe every third article
of clothing I had had venom on it I was
set and then this game came out it was
just like a dream come true because like
he's so tough and cool in this game he
still overpowered it for that pause for
a second I thought I had roars Wolverine
imelda in bed for the most part like
normal enemy types that you fight are
just complete chump change but no one
can do anything to venom unless they're
a box ID so if you don't got superpowers
you don't stand a chance
were you just die already or may not die
but you know whatever you do that's
close enough for that
I guess this game had to balance it
because we'll bring to heal a lot faster
than I can I have certainly beyond to
like the second part of the boss fight
by now I kind of absolutely destroy you
it is not getting you any mercy god this
is embarrassing this guy fought the
whole there we go
okay these segments are super easy with
a ps3 controller because of the way the
trigger is kind of curved inwards so
that those used to be like super
difficult on ps2 and are just ended
nothing me babe whoa there's something a
block I can do bro yeah really a little
bit how do you how do you how do you
like that little man oh no the phone's
ringing it's probably my school telling
me I was late again today haha
God my attendance is just the worst okay
back to back to whatever we are doing
just now I forgot what we were doing
oh yeah City gold this is so helpful I
like that they just put a thing in there
it tells you what you got to do all
right
the race metals well there's one like
right over here that we could do another
question was uh which one is my favorite
voice actor for spider-man and I have
two I think Josh Keaton is like you know
he just absolutely killed it in all the
video games and animated series that he
did and part of me like despises the
planet I live on for the fact they cut
his tract for dialogue and Avengers
Earth's Mightiest Heroes and in his
replaced it with Drake Bell and I also
like Shawn Marquette the voice actor
from this game because he actually
unlike any of the others he was actually
a teenager when he recorded this and he
just had like this kind of he has this
sort of authenticity that the rest never
had all right whatever I'll take it
silver these that get degrees I guess
alright now we got to go swinging around
and hope something bad happens as most
superheroes do well I didn't take long
thanks New York your crime level has
yielded so many interesting stories over
the past century how come there's no
superheroes in Detroit you feel like
they need someone over there like like
really badly
because you know actually now that I
think about it like Detroit right now
looks like host dog fight Man of Steel
metropolis oh yeah there's a poster for
Kraven I like the the posters and
advertisements in this one because
there's a little fun nod to the rest of
the universe so if I had to pick between
Josh Keaton and Sean Marquette even
though Sean Marquette I don't know what
he sounds like these days but I bet he
you know probably can't do it as well as
he did in this game mache me never got
to do it another time it'll be cool
but uh I feel like I would pick someone
more in the range of like a child actor
for a one-off thing like this but if I
needed to get like a long-running
animated animated series I would get
Josh Keaton because he's a grown man and
he can he can consistently do the voice
for a couple of years in a row you know
alright let's go
stomp some bad guys and I'll just punch
this street lamp for a second brave and
get the end of you so that is lone
little piece of shrubbery sticking out
of the concrete what someone should
really do something about that alright
where are we going oh yeah over here I
like the combat tours just because like
it gives you I don't know like the
random enemy encounters in this game
aren't quite as common and Peaks like
spider-man 2 damn right I'm spectacular
I have real good this game I like to
think I'm good at this game but then you
could also argue that this game kind of
English I'd use a combination of both
maybe
only amazing that time all right fine no
we is amazing better than spectacular
how do you decide it's superior the best
of all how do you know which how do you
know which tag line is the one that
you're supposed to get you please stop
shooting me I go without saying oh god I
just waited too long and now everyone's
getting back up
Wow another times when he launches like
15 feet off of a wall and then into
someone's face and just like kind of
feel bad for them hey my husband likes
it goes uh yeah I'm clearly kind of new
at this whole talking by myself thing
but yeah I got helped upgrade all right
a new new city goal or story mission
what oh Lord more busy work maybe I
should just grind all those out
off-screen so you don't have to worry
about them but then there'd be less of
me rambling about things I'm just going
to keep swinging in a straight line
until I see a red dot on that map any
minute now
any second it's New York there's going
to be crime right around this corner
right around does right over here yeah
there we go
wait what why is it so far up someone
about to fall off a building again yeah
sure is where's this whole city would
fall apart looking for me yeah I mean
the police are kind of incompetent and
all the other superheroes are off doing
super things you know Fantastic Four
don't give a [ __ ] about organized crime
they're always off you know hanging out
going on adventures in space in fact if
you think about a lot of the Fantastic
Four's adventures at least in the
ultimate univer
or involve them going somewhere they
shouldn't and then pissing someone off
then fighting them then going home like
they're not really crusading for justice
they're more so just like getting into
trouble constantly like spider-man's the
only one keeping the city together in
this universe and then ultimate
Daredevils is like yeah yeah
original Daredevils better what I can't
where are these I hear the noises can
someone point me in the direction of
some crime you they're sad you you seem
to know anyone who who's committed
crimes as of late you yourself are
currently jaywalking but that's only
because I stopped you halfway through
this intersection all right carry on
about your day citizen okay this whole
thing is a mess all right let's just go
no wait I saw I saw one and then as soon
as I turned around it was on okay here
we go
how many people are falling off of
buildings around here we'll need to be
more careful wait you're like wearing
like a business suit what were you doing
up there did I just work your suicide
attempt
all right well have fun continuing about
your miserable life sir okay back to
whatever I did was I was doing oh yeah
my nose I think now this is a cooler
load screen because it doesn't boil
what's about to happen
bye-bye eyewitnesses is looking quotes
sort of like a rhinoceros but bigger is
rampaging through the streets of the
city we have not yet confirmed reports
that this is a safe hey you remember the
big brain hunter looking guy and it has
to be more specific
[Music]
man Triclimate period Kenneth there keep
the Rhino guy in the ding-ding and
tended to get back you can do that with
your masks on backwards
already I like this game's idea of how
how the missions flow is though it's
always some kind of a it's always some
kind of chase sequence and that works in
spider-man's mobility or venom anything
about that and also gets you to like
like hype up for the boss fight like
it's not just running around fighting a
bunch of like you know knuckle draggers
on the ground that uh are somehow like
you're standing this is my store I need
to get that TV on guy you're getting
crushed I really like this segment of
the game you know because you're running
around kind of following this path of
caf well I hang hang on sir feel excuse
me I need to get this token all right
now I will go save you I hope I didn't
flip the menu in now I think the words
you're looking for work thank you yeah I
actually really like how that random
encounter was like saving a civilian
actually had kind of some personality I
think the game should have done more
like that because instead it's this kind
of generic you know save people from X
bad guy you don't really ever get to
talk to them but uh you know good Brian
Michael Bendis dialogue in there fun
that's something that guy can do in
space he can write it himself some
dialogue smashing holes do entire
buildings and I'll doing the math in my
head
Wow the woman chopped over that car how
the hell did you get down here this way
without dying it looks like a missile
hit this lady should be like paste by
now unless that was just like one of
those random New York sinkholes you hear
about well send me sideways and call me
Gwen's neck that's not very good
hey I already said that except in a
workplace happen all right
you NPCs climb on out while I go get my
ass kicked this is my favorite testing
ever I love it so much
[Applause]
hey you got a rhinoceros horn you just
have to be fine so since I can't finish
my lame joke don't worry nothing's
broken at my spine you ribs maybe
everything subsets I also just love to
style the cutscenes like it especially
comes through like but I wish they'd
have done at least one more game in that
sort of style this game is kind of a
beard out layer but it's not based on a
movie and it's not one of the beam ox
game it's just kind of I guess there's
not such weird thing that big time super
he always says Big Time superhero like
that oh I think when you actually get to
the big time you just going to realize
it's a slight costume different beer oh
this is before the ultimate version of
scorpion got added which is another
clone this is a job I ever talked about
how tired I am a clone I'm really tired
of Klump I actually read through the
entire Clone Saga beginning to end
and lives with Mantua big crazy guy
wrecking ball
it gives me an idea spider-man
homecoming these moments like this
freeze using with ingenuity to like
figure out a way that click on a big
dumb Cooper going out
that didn't work out in my favor but
wait why are you not what dude what the
hell
throw a punch no over here though this
way there you go good work
touken priorities I need more I don't
even know I'm picking these up I don't
even give a [ __ ] okay this I beat this
boss fight without taking a single bit
of damage once when I was like nine and
I was so proud and I was talking about
it for days on end and no one was around
when it happens but you know no one saw
how badass I was I've already taken
damage before the boss fight even
started so you know I'm not going to get
that one
I think this is the coolest Rhino law
sites in all the game because the only
one that does not involve tricking him
into running into something that's
covered electricity and then when he
gets stuck is over and just hit him like
that's not that's still played out whoa
in fact spider-man 3 just didn't have
that kind of fight with Rhino in it and
instead yet now because the spider-man 3
had it did that with with the lizard he
said when he's turned into that like 19
foot tall Gordon and instead the boss
fight was lizard in that one was I don't
even remember I think scorpion was there
and I think all the character models
looks really bad the game graphics are
amazing they still look great today
because Bell shaded doesn't like really
age it's it's so much of an art style
that you can just do it forever like the
Walking Dead game is going to look great
10 years from now and this one looks
great 12 years after it came out
I also wish they had done another
spider-man game in this art style
because it looks so cool plus it's
probably need to save yourself a lot of
time on texturing because you don't have
to make everything feel so hyper
realistic
oh god I got a boo-boo
I guess tonight I'm supposed to touch
those cars
yeah so you may have noticed that by now
he's blown up the same car maybe like
nine times because it responds every
time you're not looking well please just
just turn around for a sec what no but
like there we go okay that's enough all
right thank thank you for your time
you get faster and angrier the more you
do that so it gets harder the dog some
of his punches and then at one point it
starts like running through everything
you know at least the collateral damage
was definitely you know relatively close
to like one area actually Nellie
cut a hole through the entire town go to
my talk about you know it's this were
the original universe spider-man he
could just roll one of these cars I mean
he doesn't do that often because that's
like construction of properties he could
do it there we go sweet I landed right
on it take this you horn theme metal
plated rapscallion whoa okay
I convert this guy can I beat him I just
thinking I could do it this time no no I
got greedy man this is like a dark full
sauce you got that stupid cheap-ass
magic pixel even yellow I don't know
it's like making a joke about its audio
tour exactly makes sense considering
he's a giant robot Trask what does that
mean aim so familiar back away from me
masked Avenger my diminutive corpus will
not withstand your custom millions of
reasons not with the big words again
it's time to abscond this locust
Wow
must have taken a nastier beating I
thought my brain feels like it wants to
climb out of my skull okay wow that was
odd maybe I just need to take a couple
days off relax she's not be spider-man
for a few days maybe actually do
something that doesn't involve I don't
know people trying to kill me
part of me wonders what Eddie was just
doing walking around at the time
considering like the city was under
attack by a giant 19 foot tall robot man
and you know they're like right near
that car dealership there was like I
don't know how many cars exploding
I guess Eddie just doesn't care god I
wish the phone would stop ringing I
should really like you know what I
should do I should just take a
pillowcase and then just put the phone
in it and then put it in the basement of
my house since I'm on the top floor
right now and no one will ever know no
one will ever know oh hey look the
Baxter building landmark token found gee
what do I get for it anything cool
nothing all right
hey look I found it there we go I
remember it's from one of my earlier
playthroughs it was a like the eighth
time I played this game out of like 15
and I accidentally bump it into it and I
thought hey that's really cool Let's
Plays are cheap and easy
[Music]